So now that we have a basic
understanding of how the overall file
system works, why don't we take a look
at what one of these AppLockers or
Sandboxes looks like on the inside.
When an app is installed,
its Sandbox is created with
several pre-made containers.
The Bundle Container contains
the application itself, or
more specifically, a directory
that holds the executable code and
resources, like images and sound files
or whatever else is used by that code.
The Data Container,
like its name might suggest,
holds all the user and app data.
Within it are three sub-containers.
The documents, library,
and temp directories.
Temp is used for
storing very temporary data that doesn't
need to be persisted across launches.
So we're not going to be talking
about this directory in this course.
Documents and library are the
directories you want to focus on.
Documents is where user data should go,
and library is for
non-user data files or files that you
don't want to expose to the user.
Both of these directories contain
a few standard sub-directories,
such as Documents/Inbox,
Library/Applications Support,
Library/Caches, and several others.
The caches directory is important,
and we'll revisit it
along with the documents and library
directories later in this lesson.
Note that you can also create
sub-directories of your own to better
organize your files.
At app runtime, an app may also request
access to additional containers,
such as the iCloud container.
So now that we have an idea of how the
file system works and what the Sandboxes
inside the file system look like, we can
probably revisit our initial question.
Where does NS user defaults live?
If you guessed within the data
container, you'd be right.
It lives right here within the data
container inside of library.
Its actual path looks
something like this.
The file, info.myapp.mobile.plist,
is the file that contains the saved and
its user defaults.